You said and I can see that I have a defect on my BDR genes. So the BDR genes are your vitamin D receptor genes
Doesn't always mean I should be taking more vitamin D
No, so if you have
defects on your BDR genes then you have a greater propensity to
have low vitamin D levels, but it doesn't always mean you do. So I don't recommend
vitamin D usage
based upon genetics. So you want to look at your blood test of your vitamin D levels
and if they're low then we want to increase your vitamin D
consumption. So we'd increase your
vitamin D intake based upon your blood tests.
However, when you look at somebody's genes that can tell you
why you have low vitamin D levels. I've had people with I can't figure out why vitamin D level
they're only 33 and I take 5,000 I use a vitamin D every day and I have for five years what the deal
and I go and the sun and I get sun all the time. What's what's going on? Well you most
probably tell that that person has BDR gene defects and without doing their genetics if that's the case.
So it's but it does answer questions. So I don't recommend vitamin D based upon genetics. We
recommend vitamin D based upon your blood work, but it does answer questions. So why a person has
low vitamin D levels when they're taking vitamin D. Another reason why I personally have low
vitamin D levels and they're taking they've taken vitamin D their whole life. They may not they may have
clean BDR genes but they have an autoimmune disease many times autoimmune diseases can
increase the need for vitamin D and the pleats vitamin D in the blood.